au coeur de la discorde à la sainte
famille la pouponnière qui accueille une
quinzaine d'enfants de moins de 3 ans
pour encadrer ces tout petits
quatorze agents se relaient 24 heures
sur 24 seulement voilà la charge de
travail serait très inégale entre les
employés deux jours et ceux qui assurent
le service de nuit
le problème n'est pas nouveau en
novembre dernier l'administrateur
judiciaire nommé pour gérer la structure
avait accepté la mise en place d'un
planning tournant afin que tous les
agents fassent des nuits mais au début
du mois de février il a décidé de
remettre l'ancien planning en fonction
et cela ne fait pas l'unanimité on est
maintenant face à un personnel qui est
vieillissant qui ne peut plus avoir
cette endurance de travail comme il y
avait dans le temps si ce planning
répondait aux attentes dans le temps
aujourd'hui n'est plus valable et nous
aimons que nos collègues puissent en
tant qu' aujourd'hui et à des collègues
de jeu qui sont fatigués et qu'ils ne
peuvent plus continuer ainsi et ça n'est
pas que leur santé contacter
l'administrateur affirme que le
rétropédalage sur le planning tournant
s'explique par le fait qu'il faille
vérifier si son principe est bien
conforme au droit du travail
en attendant une demi-douzaine d'agents
affiliés à force ouvrière exerce donc ce
qu'ils appellent un droit de retrait